it's got to be nice to have a guy like
Greedo home right yeah hell yeah we did
a cool video too have you guys uh talked
about doing a collab project maybe you
know what greeters the work is easy we
just get it inside [__] I feel like he's
got like that like high output like yeah
just like you and your brother have like
that's him and catch you just like who I
got it from just that crazy out like
output of just
like I remember like I was talking to TK
and I was like how many this was like
maybe last year I was like how many uh
grito songs he's like bro there's like a
thousand in October brother it was a
thousand before it went in
well because like he was recording like
he wasn't gonna get out for a very long
time so it's like you know you got to
keep keep up the output like and he was
dropping in videos I remember I went to
the studio one day at around Studio that
[__] did
15 songs the next day shot 15 mini music
videos so I'm like this [__] on some
[__] right now